hey everyone this is Lucy and today I'm
joined by Elisa who is a cloud engineer
at AWS today we're going to be answering
the question what does an AWS Cloud
engineer actually do we'll also be
talking about the skills required to
become a cloud engineer and how you can
start your career in this role so Elisa
to start off with do you want to tell
the viewers a bit about yourself yeah
sure hi everyone my name is Lisa and I'm
A Cloud engineer in Amazon web services
I've been working here for about a year
now and I primarily support services
such as IAM Key Management Services and
security Hub and so on awesome so what
does the cloud engineer actually do at
AWS how would you explain the role yeah
so a cloud engineer's main
responsibility is to solve customers
issues we could get emails chats or
calls throughout the day and the range
of questions could involve how do you
use a certain service to our application
is down could you help us also as a
cloud engineer you would generally have
a main domain which is security for me
however it's also encouraged to learn
cross-domained skills so there's always
an opportunity to expand on your
technical skills wow sounds like a great
position where you get to work with
customers whilst building your own
technical skills so how did you land the
position and what was your journey like
so back in University I studied computer
science and started off my career as a
security analyst in Deloitte cyber
Intelligence Center within that role I
gained some AWS experience and found car
competing to be interesting which is
what prompted me to look for AWS
opportunities I remember I applied
through Linkedin and went through the
standard interviewing process I remember
I specifically looked for a cloud
engineer role because as a cloud
engineer you get to be more Hands-On and
early in my career I was looking to
expand on my technical skills nice okay
so speaking of applying to the role what
was your interview process like were
there any skills in particular you
thought that they were looking for
quick pause if you lead A busy life and
want to get better quality sleep I
recommend check out these sleep earbuds
sound core by Anka has recently released
a new space A10 earbuds to help more
people improve their bedtime routine
Studies have shown that better sleep can
lead to better mental health so with the
Sleep a10's built-in library of sleep
sounds you'll be able to enjoy a good
night's sleep and feel more refreshed
the next day I also just love the way
they designed it it comes with a
beautiful case that feels really
lightweight the earbuds themselves are
created so that even if you sleep on
your side you won't be able to feel the
earbuds protruding out thank you sound
call for sponsoring today's video if
you're interested in checking out these
earbuds I have a link to them in the
video description below
so for me the cloud engineer interview
process consisted of firstly a online
simulation so it included things like
emails and chats coming which would test
your priority as well as your
troubleshooting skills it also has some
technical and behavioral questions that
was followed by a for an interview as
well as a four to five hour
face-to-face interview that consisted of
Technical and behavioral questions again
for the technical interviews I think the
common expected areas of knowledge are
operating systems networking and some
troubleshooting skills in my interviews
I think the interviewers were trying to
assess my technical depth as well as the
breadth of knowledge in those areas as
well as my main domain which is security
for the behavioral interviews the
questions stemmed from Amazon's
leadership principles so I advise
preparing a couple of scenarios Oreos
per leadership principle for these
interviews so the questions could
include questions about taking ownership
which means being responsible and
accountable for your work as well as
having that learn and be curious
attitude great thank you so much for
sharing that my final question is what
advice do you have for people who are
looking to start their career as a cloud
engineer yeah firstly for those of you
who are considering to become a cloud
engineer I think it's a great role if
you're looking to expand on your
technical skills in a fast-paced
environment solving cases could involve
reviewing complex architectures and we
also have Engineers globally to whom you
can reach out for help at any time it's
also a role that people often start with
and switch to a different role later and
actually Amazon is supportive with your
individual career growth and we've got
internal Mobility programs to help you
reach that next stage of your career
lastly for those of you who are going
for the card engineer roles I think the
behavioral part of the interview is as
important if not more in the overall
process I also think the AWS
certification helped me in the
application process I had the solutions
architect associate level certification
however I still recommend gaining some
hands-on experience through you know
personal projects to have that practical
side of the knowledge because
certifications mainly for your
theoretical all right so this brings us
to the end of this video of what a cloud
engineer actually does at AWS thank you
so much Elisa for joining today and if
anyone has any questions please leave it
down in the comments below and we'll get
back to you alright bye for now
today I'm joined by Elisa who's a cloud
engineer at AWS he's a bad supporter
I'll do that I'll do this open hand
gesture
this is her do you mind if I say that
one more time they're pronounced
decorations yeah so there's always an
opportunity that's okay
it's called more skills and um
expensive skills hang on apply to my AWS
internship oh yeah
[Music]